الهروله للتطبيع
احنا اولا ما شاركش فيها هما نباركش فيها
والقضيه الفلسطينيه عندنا تبقى قضيه
مقدسه التي تتهم المغاربه بسب الجزائر
والجزائريين
فان من يقومون بها بطريقه غير مسؤوله
يريدون اشعال نار الفتنه بين الشقيقين
ايها المغاربه اتريدون الصحراء الغربيه
اذا فلتوافقوا على فتح سفارتنا لديكم
المغربيون يضعون ايديهم على رؤوسهم لسنا
اولا مطبعين وقد سابقنا بعض العرب سابقتنا
الامارات والسودان والبحرين والاردن ومصر
انه عرض مغر ولا يمكن تفويته فهل نسي
هؤلاء ان الاسرائيليين لا عهد لهم ولا
ميثاق اذا ما هي الضمانات ليضرب
الامريكانو على صدورهم نحن هنا ايها
المغربيون وها هو قلم الرئيس الامريكي
السابق الرجل الاصفر دونالد ترامب يوقع صك
الضمان للمملكه المغربيه بملكيه الصحراء
المملكه في وضع حرج بين القبول والرفض
وبين الصح والقضيه الفلسطينيه ولكن مهلا
مهلا اين الجزائر من هذا كله وكيف سيكون
الرد الجزائري البوليساريو والمغرب
واسرائيل وامريكا والجزائر في الحلبه فلما
ستكون الغلبه
تسارع الاحداث
تطورات متسارعه تشهدها العلاقات المغربيه
الاسرائيليه بعد الرساله التاريخيه التي
وجهها بنيامين نتنياهو رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي الى العاهل المغربي الملك محمد
السادس حول اعتراف تل ابيب بسياده المملكه
المغربيه على اقاليمها الجنوبيه نعم لقد
اعترفت تل ابيب بسياده المغرب على اراضي
الصحراء الغربيه وليس ذلك فحسب بل ان
اسرائيل ستقوم باخبار الامم المتحده
والمنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه التي تعتبر
اسرائيل عضوا فيها وكذا جميع البلدان التي
تربطها باسرائيل علاقات دبلوماسيه حميمه
بهذا الاعتراض ما كل هذا الاصرار لماذا
يهتم الاسرائيليون بمصلحه المغرب الى هذه
الدرجه
تسعى بشكل حثيث لبناء علاقات جيده مع
المغرب ومعظم الدول العربيه لتسيطر على
المنطقه لذا فاعترافها بان الصحراء مغربيه
مش عشان خاطر سواد عيون المغربيين كما
يقولها المصريون بل لحاجه في نفوس
الاسرائيليين وعندما يخضونها فقد يغيرون
اعترافهم هذا وانهم سيجعلونه خيطا لمساومه
المغرب على اشياء اخرى منذ عوده علاقات
اسرائيل مع المملكه المغربيه سنه 2020
اصبح المغرب الدوله المغربيه الوحيده التي
تقيم علاقات مع اسرائيل بعد قطع موريتانيا
علاقاتها مع اسرائيل في 2010 ويعتبر
المغرب كذلك السادس بين البلدان العربيه
بعد السودان والامارات والبحرين والاردن
ومصر لكننا نتحدث عن اثنتين وعشرين دوله
عربيه ست منها فقط هي من طبعت مع اسرائيل
وبعضها على استحياء بينما يظل بقيه العرب
صامدين مع القضيه الفلسطينيه ولا يعطون
اسرائيل اي وجه للتطبيق حتى يومنا هذا
ليصل لعاب تل ابيب لترقيه مكتب الاتصال
الاسرائيلي في المملكه المغربيه الى مرتبه
سفاره ولكن كان هناك عائق كبير امام هذه
الخطوه فموقف اسرائيل لم يكن واضحا من
قضيه الصحراء الغربيه اما اليوم وبعد
الاعتراف الاسرائيلي فان اسرائيل تدرس
خطوه اخرى بفتح قنصليه لها بمدينه الداخله
وياتي بعد ذلك فتح السفارات بين البلدين
ثم اعلان التحالف لتخسر فلسطين شقيقا
عربيا ويا لها من خساره ولكن مهلا مهلا
فقد صعدت اسرائيل من خطواتها وشدت الله
نحو المغرب مهروله لتعلن قبل ايام من
الاعتراف بالصحراء تعيين ملحق عسكري في
المغرب في خطوه وصفها الاسرائيليون
بالتاريخيه لانها خطوه ترفع مستوى تطور
العلاقات الامنيه بين الدولتين حتى ان
المغرب اصبح يستورد الاسلحه الاسرائيليه
بانواعها اسرائيل ليست اول من اعترف
بمغربيه الصحراء فقد سبقت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في عهد الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب وذلك وفقا للاتفاق الثلاثي
بين المغرب واسرائيل والولايات المتحده
لكن اليوم موقف الرئيس بايدن غير واضح من
الصحراء وقد تنتهي ولايه بايدن دون ان
يحسم هذه القضيه فينتظر المغرب الفائز من
سياتي بعد بايدن لكن ماذا لو فاز بايدن
مجددا هل يكفي اعتراف اسرائيل بان الصحراء
للمغرب ليستعيدها المغاربه اسرائيل نفسها
ليس لديها اجماع دولي
بانها دوله اساسا فلماذا يعطي المغرب
الاعتراف اسرائيل اهميه كبيره الصحراء
والبوليس نحن نتحدث عن الصحراء المغربيه
اقصد الغربيه وبشان هذه الحيره في التسميه
دعونا نغوص في التاريخ قليلا لنعرف سر
العداء وكثره الاسماء تعتبر ازمه الصحراء
الغربيه واحده من اطول الصراعات السياسيه
والانسانيه في العالم انها منطقه شاسعه
تقع شمال غربي افريقيا ومساحتها حوالي 266
الف كيلو متر مربع يدير المغرب نحو 80%
منها والباقي تدير موجبات البوليساريو
وعلى ذكر البوليساريو فهم مجموعه من
الصحراويين يعيشون في الصحراء وياكلون
ويشربون هناك ولا حياه لهم الا بالصحراء
انهم كالجمال يا ساده مع حوالي نصف مليون
شخص هم من يعيش في تلك الصحراء يتوزعون
على المدن الرئيسيه في المنطقه هذه
المنطقه كانت خاضعه للاستعمار الاسباني في
الفتره الممتده من
1884 الى
1976 وبعد خروجه تنازع السياده عليها
المغرب وجبهه البوليساريو فقد صعدت الجبهه
من وتيره عملياتها وقامت بالتحريض على
المظاهرات المطالبه بالاستقلال بينما اتجه
المغرب الى محكمه العدل الدوليه ومنذ ذلك
الحين اندلعت الحرب المتقطعه بين
البوليساريو والمغرب وخلال هذه المعارك
كان الكثير من الصحراويين قد لجاوا الى
الجزائر حيث يقيمون في مخيمات منذ عقود
ورغم ان النزاع في ملف الصحراء الغربيه
يوجد رسميا بين المملكه المغربيه وجبت
البوليساريو الا ان اسم الجزائر يحضر كذلك
في هذا النزاع حضور يعود بالاساس الى
احتضان الجزائر لمخيمات مقر البوليساريو
ودعمها المتواصل لهذه الجبهه رغم تاكيد
الجزائر ولو على الصعيد الرسمي انها ليست
طرفا في النزاع لكن الجزائريين يعتبرون
دعمهم للبوليساريو مساله مبدا مثل دعمهم
مانديلا في جنوب افريقيا من قبل ودعمهم
للقضيه الفلسطينيه والجزائر لا تحيد عن
مبداها كما يقول شعبها المغرب يقولها
العين بالعين
العلاقات الجزائريه المغربيه تشهد توترا
منذ عقود وليست قضيه الصحراء الغربيه
المشكله الوحيده كما ان الحدود بين
الجارتين مغلقه منذ عام
1994 وبما ان الجزائر تدعم جبهه
البوليساريو فالمغرب له ازمه جزائريه اخرى
ليدعمها نعم انها ازمه القبائل ونحن نتحدث
عن احدى اخطر الازمات التي واجهت الجزائر
في السنوات الاخيره وهي ما بمنطقه القبائل
الامازيغيه حيث انطلق منها الحراك في
الجزائر والتي تعرف بطبيعتها المتمرده منذ
عشرات السنين بدءا من تمرد عام 63 مرورا
بالربيع الامازيغي الى ان وصلت الى العام
2001 حيث اشتدت ثوره القبائل مطالبه
بالاستقلال والانفصال عن الجزائر ومن مبدا
العين بالعين يقولها المغرب تدعمون
الصحراء الغربيه اعجبت البوليساريو حسنا
سندعم استقلال منطقه القبائل فزمنوا
التسامح قد ولى وحان وقت المعامله بالمثل
وبينما ترفض الجزائر الاعتراف بمغربيه
الصحراء اعترفت بها اسرائيل اليوم وكل
يغني على ليلى ليتضح بذلك سبب الخصام بين
الجزائر والمغرب اما تل ابيب فقد اعلنت
صفها بانتظار ان تعلن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه صفها وبصراحه اسرائيل قالتها
للعلم نحن في كفه المغرب وسندعم استعادتهم
للصحراء الغربيه فماذا بعد الاعتراف
الاسرائيلي هل ستلحق دول اخرى بهذا
الاعتراف امنا قرارات اسرائيل لا تعني
الدول ولا يهتم لها احد